I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah well
[Music]
sensory talk sensor descriptions
[Music]
[Music]
great thanks Steve so I'm going to talk
about primarily about one aspect of bike
sharing but I'll set the the frame more
generally as well this is more recent
work that's joined with an undergrad at
Cornell Hong Gil Cheung and Daniel
Freund but as I say it's really based on
sort of ongoing series of papers with
that that are also with Shane and Owen
and indeed that the focus is going to be
on incentives and the picture in the
upper right hand corner is from a recent
article in an online publication talking
about city bike angels in an area of
Brooklyn and I'll tell you gradually
what bike angels are so bike sharing 101
bike sharing systems as they are at this
point predominant in in the US are the
station based systems here you see a map
of the system in in New York in a
station behind it attestation is a set
of Docs
which can be filled with bikes and the
key elements of the system is the
ability for a rider to rent a bike at
any station and return it at any other
and as I said this is ongoing work that
we did initially primarily with city
bike but but more generally now with
motivate their umbrella company
impacting their systems across North
America and city bike started in New
York in May of 2013 to give you a sense
of the volume nearly 2 million rides per
good mother weather month now believe it
its peak in Paris was 3 million as the
other sort of most recognized station
based ride-sharing system bike sharing
system and give you a sense of overall
volume between 16 and 17
rides in 2017 currently there about
12,000 bikes more than 700 really
actually more than 800 stations and
there's ongoing expansion and as I said
this has been part of work that that
that we've done with city bike since
their inception the main challenge in
running one of these systems is
imbalance that on the left you see a
station where a cyclist is arriving with
no docks available and on the right you
see a user unable to rent a bike because
the docks are all empty and in some
sense that's the key challenge is
preventing cyclists from becoming angry
at their inventory stock outs this is a
system that one gets a good sense of the
data of usage throughout the day and I
know many of you have seen this movie
but I'm going to play it again anyway
so I'm going to show you a day in the
life of New York and it's gonna start at
midnight each of those circles
corresponds to a station the diameter of
the station is proportional to the net
flow of bikes of that station red is
going to be outgoing traffic blue is
going to be in going traffic and let's
start it
oh gee no there we go
okay so it's midnight there's small
amounts of percolating effects as we
head into the beginning of the rush hour
the transit hubs at Penn Station the
Port Authority are going to turn red the
financial district is going to turn blue
and here we see it there the red the
blue for the financial district the East
Village a residential area turns red and
midterm Midtown turns blue for
commercial incoming traffic and this
explodes through the morning rush hour
now by 10 o'clock it starts fading off
there'll be a little bit of a pickup at
around lunchtime of increase of rides
and then the other key element of
bike-share traffic is that we'll see the
same thing in Reverse for the late
afternoon rush Midtown turns red the
financial district turns red the East
Village turns blue and the transit hubs
turn blue of incoming traffic so and the
afternoon rush and a bit takes a bit
longer to die down and then we percolate
back to just this noise throughout the
system ok so there you sort of see the
the texture of neighborhoods New York as
cities goes is relatively heterogeneous
in that there are there's a mosaic of
characteristics of stations that are
actually relatively physically close to
each other other cities are more
partitioned between different larger
areas of different kinds of behavior the
system of course keeps track of itself
that this shows a plot of one very
boring station in Brooklyn of the number
of by the time of day on the x-axis and
the number of bikes currently docked at
that station to give you sense why I say
that's poor of the Green Line across the
top is the capacity so this is a
relatively large station this is a
station in midtown
in contrast on three days of the same
week and you sort of see tremendous
volatility this spike for example or
maybe
clear this spike is a rebalancing truck
that a truck arrived with a large number
of bikes they got all unloaded and then
this is Midtown for 52nd and fifth so
this is a time in the lay in the evening
rush where there's just tremendous
outflow and that though that station
gets depleted almost immediately yes
what's the disincentive for just
abandoning bicycles $1,000 deposit on
your credit card good that's a pretty
strong disincentive
I mean first there are overage fees in
there that are good and please interrupt
with questions throughout although the
system does track its own data of course
we only know the transactions that did
occur not the ones that didn't occur due
to the fact that there wasn't
availability but there's a way that we
can do a sort of back of the simple back
of the envelope and take advantage of
stochasticity to to infer a bit more
signal than the data itself and to
illustrate that this is a plot that
shows the days of one month the 24 hours
in the day broken into ten minute
segments indicating are we in extreme
situation where we're almost out of
bikes you know the other hot bread is is
is out of Docs and green is just
generally good and if I look at a given
10 minutes slice as I go across the
behavior across the month oh we see that
there's variability there and so we can
in some sense infer what a data-driven
rental rate is at a given station just
by conditioning on those particular days
in which there is availability rather
than just an average over the full thing
for first time like this you can see
that quite often we're almost out of
bikes this is Penn Station
so it's one of the hardest stations to
actually manage nationwide and this
allows us to back-end to go from on the
dotted plot that you see to midtown
plots of morning and afternoon rush and
an East Village similarly in terms of
what we can back-end in terms of the
data-driven demand
weekdays and weekends are very different
not terribly surprising this is a
graphic that shows weekdays and weekends
the 25 pair two pair and to end a pair
of most used most rented routes and what
you can see of course is during the week
that there's a lot of this sort of
crosstown Midtown traffic where there is
not great public infrastructure whereas
on the weekends it's overwhelmingly
dominated by rides down the scenic west
side and through Central Park
no surprises but the data all just you
know this is all just living in the data
ok at the core of all the work that
we've done is a model of performance of
the system which is really geared
towards the idea of planning through
guided by the data and of course the the
main message is everything I just said
most trips are by computer computers by
commuters the heaviest usage is in
rush-hour the the planning period really
can be thought of as from from 6:00 a.m.
to midnight where most of the activity
occurs and then there's a quiescent
period between midnight and 6 a.m. and
and the first issue as a modeler is that
we want a way of evaluating the state of
the system as a function of where we are
in the the planning period and the
metric that we're going to think about
is we're going to posit some underlying
stochastic model of traffic of renting
and returns throughout the system
throughout the day and then if I look at
from a given point of time to the end of
the planning period
let's subject you know relative to that
stochastic model of traffic and the
current state of the system view what
the expected total number of stock-outs
either out of bikes are out of docks are
going to be in as we play out the rest
of the the rest of the planning period
really the number of upset customers in
a little bit more detail how we actually
model
the the stochastic traffic is a Poisson
flow of bikes that we have time varying
piecewise constant while some processes
that that that give both the rental rate
and return rate for each station in
half-hour intervals throughout the day
and then as I look at each individual
station that can be modeled by a
continuous time Markov chain and then
that allows us to turn the crank and I
haven't have these kinds of functions
and so so for every initial point we'll
have a cost function which is just the
expected total number of outages over
the remainder of the planning period as
I think about what happens at each
station and then I add that up over all
stations in thinking about system state
so but different stations are very
different than it's sort of just to you
know as a check I'll show you a few
plots of what those stations look like
this is the Port Authority one of those
transit hubs so on the x-axis we have
the number of bikes at 6:00 a.m. and and
the y-axis we have the cost the the
number of outages that are expected over
the rest of the day and because that's a
source of tremendous outflow at 6:00
a.m. every additional bike that I have
in the station at 6:00 a.m.
saved me one in terms of the overall
objective function and we see this nice
slope of minus 1 on that that boring
station in Brooklyn
basically as long as we had a reasonable
number of bikes
there we can get it down to expect no
stock-outs
but even so it's very insensitive to to
the original number of 6 a.m. because
there just wasn't a lot of activity
there and it was kind of balanced in and
out station in midtown again we have
this great inflow of traffic every dock
filled at 6 a.m. will lead to an
additional outage as that flow comes in
as the course of the morning rush hour
but then there's there every range of
possible behaviors in between that that
with more interesting behavior and and
for then for you know for each station
there is an associated target of how
many bikes that we would want at 6 a.m.
and then this of course gives rise to an
under law an associated optimization
problem if I've got a fleet of bikes how
do I ideally want to position them
throughout the system so as to minimize
the overall costs of the state but it
also gives us a way of sort of thinking
about the idealized allocation is over
the course of the day and that may vary
as well okay questions so indeed if we
look at the fraction so Siri will look
at two neighborhoods East Village in the
financial district and as we think about
what that optimization model gives in
terms of what is the idealized fraction
of the docks that should be full as a
function of the time of day then what we
see here is in the overnight hours we
already want things basically full but
then as we exit the morning rush and go
to the afternoon rush we want the
idealized version is this this quick
transition between wanting is completely
full to being completely empty and this
will come up as we sort of think about
the incentive system that I'll be
talking about later and in the no
opposite way in the financial district
we want know some amount of bikes but
but not completely empty because there's
some overnight traffic they work hard
and but then and it should be basically
empty through the morning but then all
of a sudden we hear it again the the
polarity of the magnets should switch
and then come the afternoon traffic we
want those stations fall yeah
because then I'm going to be having
users come in and not show up with it
there will be a doc available right so
it's this two-sided into inventory that
there is a fixed capacity of Doc's if I
if I have too many bikes there people
going to try to return bikes and there
won't be Docs and and and I'm just
reading them for the purposes of this as
in a symmetric way yeah in terms of
indications of dissatisfaction for empty
Docs is the customer register and are
they identified they register a
complaint and are they so this is this
is I mean the these are objective
functions measured by rates of traffic
and and that would not not going back to
actual specific users so we I mean again
we don't know I mean in some systems
there actually is a button on the kiosk
that tells you you you know you want an
extra 15 minutes worth of time and
you're going to move it no then be told
where you're your nearest available dock
is I know that the system in Tel Aviv
that I use has this functionality I'm
not sure that's very in bound but but
but it's not I mean in an ideal world
you know it's just as you know you're a
rideshare company keeps track of your
app openings I mean ideally if people
really went to their app as I do in
using go bike here and once didn't want
to know whether it's you know whether
the dock that I the station I there
would be a way of gaining an extra
signal of knowing that sorts but but
that's not entering into the the system
in any concrete way other questions so
one of the nice things about the
partnership with with motivate is that
we convinced them that they should just
think about social good and think about
their it clearly aligns to some extent
with with profit but since and we'll get
to pricing a minute that there are
overwhelming income stream is through
annual subscriptions understanding
exactly what what performance does or
doesn't you know correspond is is itself
a tricky modeling issue but but but this
is what they're using more or less this
is a scatter plot that shows that if I
look at how I'm thinking about the
idealized state of the system you know
apportioning bikes throughout the system
for the afternoon rush hour or the start
of their afternoon rush hour let's say
at 4:00 p.m. and the start of the
morning rush hour and I look each of
these points in the scatter plot
corresponds to one station so if all
traffic were this antipodal like the the
financial district or or like Midtown
all of the points would either be in the
upper left-hand corner or the upper or
the lower right-hand corner but you see
that the system in looking at over the
hundreds of stations
exhibits far more diverse behavior in
terms of what the idealized fraction of
docks filled for an idealized state of
the system okay
so the goal is to take this data and
help it to improve operations and to use
the this user dissatisfaction function
as a guide one of the first things is
this sort of planning question of at 6
a.m. where should the bikes be it's used
as this get bikes map as part of an
ongoing daily rebalancing but you know
when we when we started this project
years ago we had this idealized view the
the city was quiet between midnight and
and and 6:00 a.m. and that that
basically we could move the system from
the state that it was in at midnight to
the state that we wanted 6 a.m. in
contrast this is a map that shows how
the system is one particular midnight
again each of the circles corresponds to
one station and the circles go from
white to red white meaning that it's
close to the 6 a.m. optimum that it
doesn't need much rebalancing and red
meaning that it's far from the 6:06 a.m.
optimum and this is the way that things
evolved in that six hour period and I
know you're all staring and saying that
that could very well have been the same
map no it's not quiet I can point out a
few places where life did get better but
but but certainly a takeaway is that
motorized rebalancing in using the
system as it currently stands is is
really just a drop in the bucket in
terms of trying to make good on the
promise of what we think that should be
happening with the system so one
question in and this was implicit in
those first plots that I have that the
Midtown station had had under 40 docks
whereas that Brooklyn station had over
60 one question is are the docks in the
right
the system was set up in the absence of
data knowing how the system would be
used and and now we have the data so the
Docs themselves are just heavy pieces of
metal and machinery sitting on top of
the of the sidewalk a crane can come
along put it onto a flatbed and move it
over to another location or a set of
three of them over to another station
with relatively little cost if we can
reconfigure the the you know the system
itself to get better performance then
that would be something that's worth
doing and indeed that is something
that's worth doing this is a plot that
shows how the daily objective could
could improve as a function of the
number of docks moved and and the the
punch line I won't go through the
numbers is that an investment of moving
something like five hundred docks two
and a half percent of the system at that
time decreases the effect the the
overall cost incurred by as much as what
is being invested into daily motorized
rebalancing so and and indeed this not
at this scale but at a somewhat smaller
scale is already happening in has
already happened in New York and is the
same philosophy is being applied to
other cities throughout the network this
is one time if this is one time of and
indeed there there there's also analysis
that says it's not sensitive to
seasonality issues in the life
yes but I so so so Daniel is smiling
because he can show you flats which I
didn't include here because I'm not
talking I wasn't supposed to be talking
about Doc this is all framing to get to
incentives but but we can see a before
and after and that like the where where
Doc's have been moved we're seeing that
that that they there are a newfound doc
outages and yet the where that's being
moved to where we're getting increased
usage as well so just as a check
there aren't any easements or rentals so
this is a constraint that they're
different for different stations there
may be some bounds on how much bigger we
can we can do it this is all carefully
negotiated with with local neighborhood
associations and like the number of
people who have you know when they've
heard that I had anything do it they
said you took away my my parking spaces
that is it is there are trade-offs here
and there'll isn't there are no real
limitations real estate agents set to
city bike we're going to give you this
much money for setting up a private
station in our back yard so this is
super demented I think they were one or
two such instances that it existed okay
so
so this was in some sense the the system
set up in there are various ways that we
can mitigate the effects of the
imbalance that it that occurs in a given
time there's there's rebalancing
encouragement during the rush hour
rebalancing occurs overnight there's a
notion of surge capacity that can be
installed by valets in Corral's that can
be positioned throughout the system but
what I really thought fit in especially
with the the mornings talks was this
notion of incentives so in some sense
the only reason I'm talking about
incentives rather than differential
pricing is that City by New York City
Bike Share has agreements with this
Department of Transportation of the city
of New York as to how pricing is going
to exist to to work and it's as dumb as
it comes it is really you can get a day
pass you can get a three-day pass or
really an overwhelming fraction of the
usage is based on a one hundred and
fifty five dollars for the year annual
subscription all-you-can-eat that and
what we see and you know day there are
many rate users that that you know ride
upwards of a hundred times a year I'm
already up to 92 rides on go bike this
year that so they're subscription isn't
paying for for the rebalancing that the
costs that are incurred and and this is
worked in you know this is
non-negotiable so what we would like to
do is encourage rides that help the
system so we can charge more for the you
know overused downstream rides but we
can incentivize users to make use of the
system up upstream that that actually
help and they give us a cheaper form of
crowdsourcing rebalancing and we've
worked with them over a a couple years
by now in leading towards this program
which they call
angels so so how does this work you open
your app and you can see a map and these
are all just screenshots off of the web
so this is this Israel of stations where
you want to drop what you get
incentivized to drop off stations where
you will get incentivized to pick up you
can earn a point at either end and you
this is just a point scale that the
riders earn points by by helping the
system there are various levels for you
know rewards that you get originally it
was set up more in the context of a
raffle for giving out prizes now they're
just more sort of you know ten points
you get that 25 points that there is a
leader leaderboard
that's gamified and then there are sort
of your lifetime angel status as opposed
to two week intervals and then they're
there you know user quotes that are on
there which I just I like to do a bike
angels workout where I'll bike North and
Central Park to an empty station then
run back down the park and repeat a few
times
[Laughter]
anyway so so in the evolution of this
setup in general this was an education
for me in terms of understanding the
innate caution of the corporate entity
oh because it was clear that this made
sense and it was also
something that from the moment we first
proposed it there was a good deal of
pushback of well this would confuse
users that that this would be too
complicated to to manage and one of the
trade-offs was that in the first year
when they ran a system-wide pilot they
invited 10% of the users 1% signed up to
be bike angels that map was static the
there were a certain set of stations in
the morning that you got a point for
renting there was a certain set of
stations you got a point for whichever I
didn't say renting maybe I said say they
twice but you know what I rent
and there was a fixed period of time
that those incentives were in place for
the morning rush hour and then a similar
set up for the afternoon ok so yes and
so they initially there were some amount
of raffles that there were some master
cards that that that that would master
card was a sponsor and so that there
were some some cash equivalent prizes
the standard thing that they converge to
is this sort of one-week extension of
your annual subscription for free which
of course is a great is it win-win
situation because I mean you're
encouraging use by the people who are
making it easier to run the system
overall but they may be you still I mean
that initial membership so in principle
you could just keep extending it by by
you know you could go for free
indefinitely
having played the initial membership
but still having to incur that fixed
cost up front so I won't go through the
details about how the target set of
rides were generated but we looked at
data from that first year in a limited
time interval of weeks in the in the the
incentive system was active and all of
the rides that were at the were from
these incentivized stations and so each
of the points that you see here
corresponds to one incentive one ride
which is incentivized either at the at
the start or at the end and this is just
across them the morning rush hour so
this is a question over over from 6:00
to 2:00 to noon and what I'm indicating
for each point is then what was the
change in those cost curves and those
user to satisfaction functions as a
result of that ride so you know a ride
like this is one where you know we
really did want to do that incentive
that incentivizing because that really
improved the overall state of the system
is measured by the user dissatisfaction
functions the this ride we certainly
didn't want to in or that pickup return
we didn't want to incentivize because it
actually made the the cost function
worse yeah yes yes indeed and that is
that's the way the system was structured
so in some sense we just completely
decoupled pickup and drop off in terms
of evaluation so in an idealized world
if I painted all of the points that were
incentivized red and all those that were
not incentivized blue this is this is
the scatterplot I would want well or
maybe not maybe that's not fair because
after all
there is some cost to each incentivize
point that it is a currency that has
some implicit value and so one might
want to instead think about a different
bar and saying that that that these are
the ones who really wanted to
incentivize versus versus the points
below but that's the kind of threshold
and and and calibration that one should
think about so there are a number of so
so there number of ways in which one
might think about determining which
stations get incident devised or pick up
or return what I already started talking
about was this purely static way we just
determined a set of stations and it
stays that way throughout the trial and
this is what that first years data
looked like for that time period in
terms of which ones we incentivize and
which ones we didn't and you know it's
like arts you know it you might think
it's good you might think it's bad it's
it there's sort of room for
interpretation there I mean there's
certainly you know there's a lot of red
that's up there that we incentivize good
rides and you know there's you know the
things we didn't want to incentivize we
mostly didn't incentivize but you know
there's still a fair amount of red
that's that's that's below zero and
there's still even some blue that's
that's that that sort of left on the
table put another way this is a
histogram of the rides so as we think
about the the change of the objective
you know how we actually did in terms of
presenting we're incentivizing a fair
amount of negative or not improving
rides and it shouldn't be surprising if
you go back to those plots I showed
earlier because as I think about the end
of the morning rush hour then at some
point I'm incentivizing exactly the
wrong thing that I was that I want
that if I'm incentivizing people to take
bikes out of the financial district at
10 a.m.
maybe that's already too late because I
that you know that that bike really
should stay there for when the polarity
flips and that should be then available
for the afternoon and so so maybe that's
not certainly taking advantage of data
that's available it certainly makes a
lot of sense so so one can ask the
question who can we actually just
consider what the state of that station
is and that's perhaps a better anyway be
in general when there's rain the system
isn't stressed in the same sort of way
and and those are easy days to manage
overall but but this is exactly the
question of am I going to think about
this in an online way versus an offline
way am I going to make decisions
throughout the the given rush hour
period based on the state of that
station or am I going to make a decision
up front instead so for example a policy
we call static hindsight is that at the
start of any rush hour we're gonna make
a decision based on the last W days and
we're just going to live with that
decision for this is the period that
we're going to incentivize it or we
might do it in an aggregated basis based
on neighborhoods and that will cluster
the but again in a static way now in
contrast one can and again one of the
the issues that came up with motivators
that they wanted the planet loopy the
way in which the policy appeared to the
user to be relatively simple so they
didn't want a station being incentivized
and then not incentivized and then
incentivized to Radek within one given
period in some said they wanted a
contiguous period of time and and indeed
under the right conditions one can prove
that that there are policies that are
optimal and conserve that and then one
can compute if you knew all the data
advanced what was the idealized interval
for that
those are static policies and then one
the set of policies that that exactly
would would enable us to cope with
changing conditions we are what I'll
call dynamic policies the most user
unfriendly one it's just you get that
you take the ride and you get the
incentive you get the point if it was a
good ride after the fact or it isn't we
know whether or not it changed the
objective function and that's that's
what I'll call the dynamic but of course
motivate doesn't want that at all but
one thing we can do is we can say we can
look at the last 30 minutes and say if
the system were structure the last 30
minutes does that make sense to do that
and we can do that either in a station
by station basis or clustered and and we
can know 30 is their arbitrary number
but that's actually what the system is
using today and just to give you a sense
this is this the analogous scatterplot
again looking back at last year's I mean
the previous year's data of when I'm
using that 30-minute clustering model in
order do that and you can see that that
that that the transition from red to
blue is is much more consistent with
what we want for our objective and
there's some numbers but we won't worry
about that so just a few thoughts in
conclusion they as a data-driven
exercise in in helping to crowdsource
rebalancing this worked well the figure
that they talked about last week was
that on balance there are a comparable
number of of crowd-sourced rebalancing
trips to what motorised rebalancing does
which of course from a sustainability
point of view is
station based bike share is only the tip
of the iceberg what's coming and is is
around in particularly in China but but
in in in Europe and with with with
scooters and alike it's non station
based approaches are going to be the way
of the future and I would maintain that
pricing and now we don't have to call it
incentives because there isn't a fixed
thing is really going to be critical in
in making those systems work in a way
that balances operational needs and
maintenance needs with with the customer
availability and and and and so I think
there many interesting challenges there
even if you look at a city like Seattle
where there are multiple dhoklas bike
sharing systems there's them there
there's room for interesting work in a
sort of game theoretic way of having one
pricing model against another bit that
that gets the both the asymmetry of flow
and the trade-offs between clustering
for for operations and and dispersion
for availability
so with that I'll have you take some
questions
[Applause]
one versus the other
so I just don't know I mean it's the the
simple and truthful answer I bet that
this was a program we proposed and sort
of their broad outlines to to New York
City Bikes sir and though we proposed
initially to be raffle based and they
backed away from it being more raffle
based too but I think there's an
interesting there would be there's
certainly a lot of room for work in that
sort of mechanism design all kinds of
questions of how do you maintain user
interest in being willing to know should
should should you ramp up incentives to
do you start and back away there this is
all you know purely speculative it and
people going by the seat of their pants
rather than with sort of well
substantiated science state which is
actually quite complicated and like yeah
I mean you have to advertise the total
prize that it's being raffled away and
you know these get their odds of winning
are bounds on the odds of winning are
yes
part of my solution is the puzzle just
made improvement objective functions per
dollar spent
I would guess that it is possible
however given that they're spending very
little on this I think I know which way
the the outcome will go